Michael Knowles is the host of the
Michael no he joins us now to weigh in
Michael the New York Times is worried
you know I think the New York Times
worrying about Republicans winning
elections is the definition of a New
York Times op-ed and so this is no
surprise we've heard this before they're
already making excuses that's what this
is about so they're blaming racism or
they're blaming this ISM or that ISM
because after 2016 they had a lot of egg
on their face
specifically the New York Times they
actually had to apologize for getting
that election so wrong yeah they're
already setting it up we've been
promised this blue wave for how long now
two years and what are we actually
looking at from the polls seems like
more of a blue trickle already are
seeing that race in Texas Robert baito
o'rourke they're saying Oh even if he
loses it will be a moral victory which
is a synonym for a loss all around
what is the worry you know they promised
us in 2016 that if Trump won the sky
would fall the economy would collapse we
would have wars abroad this and that
look around there the boy who cried wolf
what has happened the economy is booming
we have record low joblessness we have
relative peace abroad renegotiation of
trade deals so what are they gonna say
now this time we're super serious
seriously believe us of course not you
know that this word credibility has been
bandied about and abused for the last
several weeks with regard to justice
Cavan well the New York Times has a real
credibility problem Michael to your
point though about crying wolf it goes
deeper because when the president was
pulling out of the Paris climate Accord
when the tax cut was being passed we had
various people like Nancy Pelosi saying
people are gonna die because of this
perhaps Armageddon it's all the rest and
as you suggest when it turns out well
the economy's actually doing pretty good
does the argument just fall under its
own weight
you know you three look very healthy I
feel healthy I think that President
Trump hasn't killed very many people
this is really the political bridge
Donald Trump which is that it's that
humor it's that mocking his opponent
it's owning the libs to use the phrase
and when you do that you drive your
opponent's crazy when the Democrats get
angry the Democrats
stupid and that's what we've been seeing
for so long now they're calling for mob
attacks on Republicans in restaurants on
Republicans where their children sleep
they're getting really really worked up
and these are political mistakes it
backfired on judge Cavanaugh it's
backfired time and time again and I hope
that President Trump keeps it up and
keeps laughing at them all the way to
Election Day because then Democrats are
really going to have something to cry
about
Michael briefly when if ever do you see
that messaging ever changing when do you
see Democrats coming to grips with
reality I think they're held hostage by
their base you know their base is
overwhelmingly young I think it's a
millennial problem you know you've got
this coddled generation that has been
indoctrinated and leftism they always
get what they want and they're furious
they're crying in the street they're
throwing these hysterical temper
tantrums like that man talking to Mitch
McConnell what are they going to do you
know president Trump has made huge gains
with key Democrat demographics with
black voters with Hispanic voters
support has surged it's even doubled
until they admit their problem the first
step to recovery is admitting that you
have a problem until they admit they
have a problem I only foresee things
getting worse for them yeah
Michael Knowles thank you for your time
we really appreciate it early up there
on the west coast thank you